hello folks welcome to rational science
another edition of
the number one physics
science
site in the world the only physics site
everybody else does mathematical physics
they move concepts around
anyways today we're going to be talking
a little bit about the flat earthers
again we there's uh
something that they don't seem to
understand after one month of trying
so we're going to try to rub it in even
further today maybe someone will
pick up on it and understand it finally
then we have uh
we're going to be talking about
the scientific method we're going to
compare against the rational scientific
method
turns out nobody seems to know what
science is out there as well
they're still running with the 17th
century version
of science
400 years later
and we're going to look at our science
critic made a video
and criticizing the scientific method
and we're going to address some of the
issues that he raised
specifically visualizations
and finally we're going to open up the
floor for questions and comments that
people made since last time
the only thing i want to mention uh is
that
um
i'm wondering
[Music]
i hope everybody can hear me anyways um
um what was i gonna say i'm gonna say
that um
i got over my coven i had covered for
about
um
a little over a week maybe like 10 days
and then i went in and i had a positive
test
and then i went in last tuesday got a
negative test so
i guess i'm out of it i got i still have
a little bit of congestion that was left
over i hope that dies
hopefully before the summer's over
anyways uh the important thing there is
that i got the documents to be able to
travel i don't care about kobe but i do
care about being able to travel without
any hassle okay so let's get on with our
[Music]
flat earthers what's the issue with the
flat earthers well they raised an issue
about a month ago now and it looks more
or less like this
we have a balloon inside a car
the car accelerates
and instead of the balloon going
backwards as you know intuition would
tell you
it goes forward it's almost scary okay
it's like someone pushed it from behind
okay this is what it looks like more or
less the car accelerates
and like everything goes backward
including you but the balloon goes
forward
okay
and the explanation for this is that air
accumulates
behind
the balloon and because there's more
uh air behind it
that's what's pushing the balloon
forward okay so that is
the um
the explanation okay
and so here here let me show it to you
in a different format this is more or
less what it looks like okay
we have a car we have the balloon right
there in the middle as soon as the car
accelerates okay the balloon instead of
moving backwards it moves forwards
why does it move forward well the
uh
explanation the mechanism is that air
moves to the back
of the car suddenly momentarily and
that's what pushes the balloon forward
because there's more air behind the
balloon than in front of the balloon
the million dollar question that i asked
which some people still or most people
still don't
understand cannot understand the
question is what causes the air to
accumulate in the rear of the car that's
the question we're not asking you to
tell me yes it does which is what
everybody more or less tells me you know
it does accumulate in the back
no the question is what causes it to
accumulate in the rear of the car that's
the question okay
okay so um
we have a couple people say what does
this have to do with the flat earth
okay
and here they are i assume they are flat
earthers maybe they are
flat universers okay so it's one of
these two if one fell says i'm not sure
what this has to do with the flat
earthers and the other person says this
has nothing to do with flat earth again
i don't know if these are flat earthers
or flat universers okay maybe maybe
you know they take after einstein they
believe in uh
the w map and uh big bang and all that
stuff could be one of those
uh there's another possibility that they
could be electric universers okay and
that's what the uh electric universers
essentially believe in you know they use
vortices plasma
uh they think everything's done with
electricity okay
so uh you know maybe maybe these folks
are electric universers and you know i
have a problem with electric
universers uh because i put them in the
same boat essentially as the flat
earthers and the flat universers you
know the math magicians i put them all
in the same boat that's 99 of humanity
out there okay why do i put them in the
same boat well because
um
they make a lot of
errors in logic and they make errors in
logic because they never define their
terms
that's that's essentially what it comes
down to what it boils down to the other
one is that they use the same
entities we can call them entities they
use the same words as the
establishment mathematical physics which
they complain against
okay
okay so um
so what's the issue well um with the fla
with the
uh electric universers these are my
gripes against them and this is in a
nutshell i've talked about them a little
more extensively in the past i'm just
gonna go
real quick uh run down of what's
specifically wrong with them okay just
bullet kind of thing you know blank
blank blank blank there it goes okay so
this is it electric universers also
known as thunderbolters you know they
like to use that call themselves the
thunderbolts okay
and the first problem is that they
theorize that gravity is electricity
okay this is essentially their their
main argument okay that gravity is
electricity
and uh here you have one of them okay he
says the following he says the electric
universe thunderbolts of the gods they
say it is not gravity that makes things
fall to the earth as some ignorant
astrophysicists might tell you aha
thank god we have some of these people
who enlighten us says it is dielectric
acceleration
between the ionosphere and the earth
okay so he's going to
accelerate something he calls dielectric
whatever that is
okay and
so he continues says these electrostatic
charges
are one quintillion times stronger than
gravity here at the surface
charges
you know there's no such thing as a
charge okay
and uh so this will never figure that
out so he talks about charges which is a
word he inherited from the establishment
the same as establishment that he
criticizes but he takes the same
language he got from them he uses the
word charge there is no such thing as
charge and it's irrational to use the
word charge in physics okay
continue says gravity takes place
between electrically neutral bodies and
supposedly causes one body to orbit
another
very amusing stuff okay
and yeah so they do believe that gravity
is electricity
and uh it doesn't stop there the problem
is that they never defined electricity
not one person in the electric universe
understands
knows you know what electricity is they
never defined the term
and here you have an uh attempt made by
one uh electric universer
okay and uh
he is a
big shot at the thunderbolts project
and he asks what is electricity and then
he says electricity is a catch-all term
that describes several different
phenomena great okay so we don't know
very well it looks like very iffy start
but then he continues says electricity
consensus opinion is lacking precision
reducing electric terminology into
smaller units is impossible because it
lies at the bottom of the lexical well
okay
so the question here is he starts out by
saying oh by the way we we don't know
exactly what electricity is because it's
a semantic issue
that's essentially what he's saying here
but then he continues says electricity
which we define as the what
flow of electric charge
particles of charge
and you look up charge it's a property
of matter that causes it to experience a
force
in other words charge is a property
it's an adjective not a noun charges a
qualifier of something okay
and yeah a charge is just 1.6 times 10
to the minus 19 coulombs that's it's
just a value that's what charge is and
what they're saying whenever they say
they move a charge or a particle or char
of of charge what they're doing is
moving a number they're moving so many
coulombs that's what they're moving
and so but it says
electricity is the flow of electric
charge but then they turn uh they end up
accelerating electricity itself and we
end up with a flow of flows
okay it says electricity travels through
a circuit continuously
so what do you mean electricity travels
i thought you said electricity is a flow
now it turns out that the flow is
traveling
and then it messes it up completely
saying electromagnetic energy flows
well energy cannot flow because energy
is a concept you cannot have a concept
traveling now you know
concepts don't travel things travel okay
and then
finishes it off saying electricity moves
through a dc circuit
and so yeah we have all these concepts
that are traveling and yeah it comes
down to them never having defined what
electricity is they have no idea what
electricity is but it's it's in their
name electric universe okay
and um and they have this notion that
it's a little ball
which they call charge and that's what's
going to flow
and so they believe that charge is a
ball that's what they think charge is
and so they have these little balls
rolling around the circuit
they use the positive and negative signs
from the establishment no one has ever
determined what positive and negative
mean
in physical terms they just use positive
and negative to distinguish one from the
other they could have said uh a and z
they could have said north and south
east or west they could have used any
any symbol the fact that you put a plus
and a minus doesn't mean that you
understand what that plus or minus
represents in physical terms
they do invoke the planetary atom okay
that's niels bohr's planetary model
and so they're going to do electricity
ionization and maybe even quantum jump
they do it all with this planetary model
okay so so the problem here is that they
borrow a a model which is
not only ridiculous
right because there's no way of showing
to begin with why that electron doesn't
fall towards the positive proton or
nucleus or why it doesn't spontaneously
fly away outside that circle that um
dotted circle there
okay so
to use the planetary model of the atom
to talk about electricity is already a
no
it's a non
non-starter okay
they think an ice cream cone is a vortex
they anything that they see that looks
like that is a vortex
they propose that plasma's a thing
okay
and no plasma is not a thing and it
takes an electric universe or a
thunderbolter
years and years to understand the
argument there they don't understand why
plasma is not a thing
and yeah it's
good luck trying to convince them of of
what they don't know okay
and then they use these cosmic filaments
as interconnections as proof that
everything is interconnected in the
universe the problem with that is
they're going to build their cosmic
filaments their inner connections
they're going to build them with that
atom there which is you know made of
discrete particles
so they have all this uh connection
uh outside out there in the universe and
it's all done with this uh
these discrete particles and then the
question arises assuming even that they
had it correctly you know they they
somehow imagined it correctly the
question is you know electricity as far
as i know flows one way
and so if it goes from one star to
another
which star is the positive which
star is the negative pole
or are they switching back and forth it
alternate current uh you know
they never really explained that
so all these elements that they
show as curticues sometimes when they
look when they
really zoom in in that region
vortices vortix right uh
they're supposedly just particles
electrons
moving from one star to another one
galaxy to another and they create this
uh filament universe
and again in which direction are the
electrons flowing are they flowing in
one direction first and then you wait a
million years for you know for the
electrons to come back
you know so none of this is is really
very clear okay with the electric
universe they have a lot of problems so
yeah i put them in the same boat as flat
earthers there's no difference and i put
them also with the flat universers the
mathematicians who move concepts around
and that's where all these people the
flat earthers and the
electric universers get their language
from they get their language from
mathematical physics okay
so that's the starting point which is
not very good already for the flat
earthers i consider them all flat
earthers okay so if you want to know why
this is a flat earth issue well now you
know
okay so here we have one fellow and he
says
the air in the car has a higher density
in the back of the vehicle than it does
in the front
no kidding
i think he figured this out all by
himself okay
has he's told us the cause
no all he's got is a description he's
just telling us there's more density in
the back of the car he hasn't
told us what caused their
the density to increase in the back of
the balloon okay why is the density
higher in the back of the car when you
accelerate that's the issue that's the
question
and he continues this means that the net
force and the balloon due to collisions
with the air will be in the forward
direction again all he's doing is
describing he hasn't told us the
mechanism
okay
so uh that's not very helpful because
all he's doing is just stating
the obvious that
air is higher in the back of the car and
lesser in the front of the car when the
car suddenly accelerates okay so why did
that happen what caused it to happen
that's the question the cause not the
description that it does we know that we
understand that we want to understand
what caused it and that's where we're
having problems getting people to
understand the question the cause the
mechanism the physical mechanism okay
here's another fellow and a
flat earther and he says the following
says a dome keeps it in and the earth is
motionless the earth being fixed and
motionless makes the entire question
moot
absolutely loved it okay so here here
goes our flat earther okay here we have
uh this is your world or at least this
is what most flat earthers believe in or
illustrate or you know
set in motion
is the sun moving is the moon moving and
you can see the moon is moving one
direction the sun is moving in the other
direction
if the sun is moving if the earth is
moving if the sun is moving and the moon
is moving
isn't the earth changing its location
with every atom that comprises the sun
with every atom that comprises the moon
so yeah
the earth is moving with respect to
those objects because they are moving
with respect to the earth
what is motion well first you got to
define motion in order to be able to
talk sensibly about it and the problem
we have right now is that people have
not defined the word motion
motion two locations okay of an object
so we have two locations
and if the sun is at a second location
the earth moved with respect to that
second location the same with the moon
if the moon moved from one location to
another
the earth suddenly changes location with
respect to the moon therefore the earth
does move no matter who on in the world
in the universe it says the earth
doesn't move the earth moves as soon as
you move because the earth is moving
with respect to you if you jump
right the earth suddenly change its
location with respect to you
so if you moved hopefully the uh earth
move with respect to you
so yeah if if you want to move the earth
it's very easy just jump and and you
move the earth
okay that's how simple it is okay so um
unless it's stuck on turtles but that's
a different story
okay so yeah
the earth does move no matter what no
matter what any flat earther says
there are no turtles under the earth and
even if they were we could get the earth
to move anyways because we would all we
have what we would have to do is just
jump okay as soon as you jump and run
you're moving the earth
in the opposite direction again if i
want to move god
it's very simple god can be in the 26th
dimension for all i care but look at me
move god
see god is changing his location with
respect to the tip of my finger
okay so as soon as my finger goes up
it's got one location and god has a
certain distance with respect to that
point as soon as i move it down it's got
a different god's got a different every
atom in his body or whatever he is you
know he's changing his location with
respect to my finger as soon as god
changes his location he moved he moved
with respect to my finger so not even
god all powerful god can avoid moving if
i don't want him to
god god uh
god gonna move whether he likes it or
not i'm gonna move him okay
and so yeah there's no such thing as no
motion not in the universe not in this
universe maybe in another parallel
universe
okay here's another
big brain okay
all these uh theorists with big ideas
as well says the video asks what causes
the air to go back yeah correctly
nothing does air stays still
okay so far he's got a description okay
until it's forced to move by its
container the car okay so far
description all he said is it moves okay
or stand still the air stand still the
car moves right the accelerating
interior surface of the car starts
accelerating some air molecules
okay i guess he's saying that the back
of the car is hitting against some
molecules and
squeezing them against other molecules
in front of them so that they all pile
up in the back of the car
that again is a description so far he
hasn't explained
why well we'll get to that in a second
essentially we want to know
why some molecules are standing still
while the car is pushing the first few
molecules that's that's going to be the
issue
but because it's gas okay the average
acceleration of the air lags the
acceleration of the solid car body okay
solid objects accelerate immediately
okay he hasn't explained why okay gases
only accelerate the molecules that
contact an accelerating surface again
he's just
saying these things he hasn't explained
anything but then he concludes he says
how does this not explain what is
happening
so he hasn't explained what causes the
air to stay behind the air molecules
before
the car touches them or before other
molecules of air comes in contact with
them okay and i'm going to show that in
a minute okay in a little more detail so
keep that in mind
okay let's move forward here uh here
again is um
this file and he just concludes he says
the air molecules are accelerated more
slowly than the van because they are not
in direct contact with a van okay
irrelevant because we're not talking
about the ones that move we're talking
about the ones that stand still
they are only accelerated when they next
encounter an accelerating interior
surface of the van again we know all
this okay so these people just repeat
over and over
again that it does and they think
they've got an explanation
the issue is well we're going to get to
that again i'm going to illustrate for
these people so they understand the
question right now they don't understand
the question
so here's another uh
felt with big ideas okay
says why does anyone need to explain the
particle not moving seems pretty simple
enough that the air is to some extent
just being left behind there's nothing
required to hold it back it's almost
like asking why you stayed behind when
your neighbor drove away
well it's not exactly like that see
there's a little bit of a difference and
i illustrated the this the other day but
i guess he
he doesn't have the brain part to
understand what i explained the other
day so i'm going to explain one more
time for those of you who
have a little more intelligence okay
here it is okay here we build a tree
uh build a car on top of a tree okay so
we built the car on top of the tree the
tree is stuck to the ground
okay
we got that so far
the tree is not touching any part of the
inside of the van in other words the
bottom part is completely gone okay so
the tree is just stuck to the ground and
we built a van over the tree okay that's
the situation here
in this sense
the tree is in the same boat as the
particle the molecule of air or you
could say an atom it doesn't really
matter we have a particle floating
inside the fan neither the tree nor the
particle are touching any part of the
van
the own end are both inside the band the
only difference is that tree is stuck to
the ground whereas the particle is not
okay that's our starting point
we're now going to accelerate the van
okay
what do you think is going to happen
well if we accelerate the van the tree
is going to stay behind because it's not
touching any part of the inside of the
van
it is stuck to the ground the ground is
preventing the tree from moving
okay
and the question is what happens to the
particle what we are interested in is
what happens to the particle and here it
is so we accelerate the van and suddenly
the tree is left behind we understand
that it's left behind until it touches
the back of the truck i guess right
because it's stuck to the ground and the
ground is preventing the tree from
moving the question is why did the
particle stay behind these people are
saying nothing
forced the particle to stay behind
oh hold it what forced the tree to stay
behind wasn't it that it was stuck to
the ground
well if the particle was left behind
maybe the particle is stuck to the
ground somehow as well or something came
in contact with the particle and
prevented it from moving forward
obviously that something is invisible
and intangible something you cannot see
or touch or determine through some kind
of experiment we can't use eyes or hands
here okay that's the issue
okay so again the particle
and the tree both stay behind that's the
question
we understand the tree that's straight
forward but the question is why did the
particle stay behind okay what prevented
from moving forward what kept it in
place
is it also stuck to the ground like the
tree
that's the question that's the million
dollar question these people are saying
no
nothing is in contact with a particle it
just stayed behind this is more or less
like saying you know when i do my
pencil experiment right i let go of the
pencil okay
and it always falls to the ground
the question is what brought it down
what caused it to come down
and these people are answering it just
does
well why doesn't it go upwards why does
it go to the left why does it go to the
right
why does it always come down
and they say it just does and they tell
you you know maybe they tell you it's
mass it's density it's gravity
well that's not an explanation that's
what we're trying to figure out what is
mass what is density what is gravity
that's what we're trying to figure out
what causes
these phenomena
and they say well there's nothing
causing it because
they can't see or touch anything that's
in contact with the pencil
and the question is
is this something we're going to
determine through c and touch
can the mediator
of gravity
mass
inertia whatever uh can the mediator the
one who causes
uh
these phenomena the one that mother
nature uses father universe right
[Music]
is there something there's something in
contact with a pencil or or is
is it
something that we're someday going to be
able to see and touch
and so they say nothing is in contact
with a pencil because they can't see or
touch it
but then they have the uh irrational
definition of the word object of what a
thing is what an entity is all these are
synonyms by the way in physics okay
something is there that we cannot see or
touch
and therefore the definition of thing of
object of entity is not that which you
can see or touch
because obviously there's something here
that you cannot see or touch which is in
contact with a pencil which is pulling
it down or maybe it's something up here
that's pushing it down but it's got to
be a something
that you cannot see or touch
that's the issue and so the question
here is again here you have the particle
stay behind and i say nothing
caused it to stay behind nothing came in
contact with the particle nothing
prevented it from moving forward it just
stays there
that's what they that's their answer it
just stays there until something pushes
it
and so this file says well it's like you
know um
your neighbor leaves you with this car
you're you know you stay behind
but it's not the same situation see if
you're inside
the car
inside the van right
and he moves forward you will move
towards the back you will be
thrown backwards
either because you're
pushed backward pulled backwards or
because you stayed in place and the car
accelerated with respect to you okay so
this is this is where we stand okay
and uh so these are the questions we
need to
answer and again it's not the same thing
to say that
uh the car left that your neighbor's car
left you behind because if you're inside
the van like the tree is inside the van
the only reason the
trees stay behind is because it's stuck
to the ground if the tree were floating
in the air
would it hit the back of the truck or
not would it stay in place or would it
move
with the with a car
and you say well if it's sitting it on a
seat for example it'll move forward
because it's rigid
okay so we're going to make a
distinction between that which is rigid
like a steel beam
and that which is not rigid like liquids
and gases
or you
you're not rigid either so when
something accelerates you you're left
behind right and that's what we're gonna
get to okay
okay so
another fellow just says in there
another flat earther i guess it says if
the band is moving the molecule will
shoot to the back
so this fellow uh doesn't believe that
uh it stays still he says it shoots
backwards something
is shoot uh pushing it or pulling it
backwards to the back of the car that's
what he thinks so we have all these
versions there okay not everybody thinks
in the same way and again here here you
have a situation i presented in the past
uh and take a look
look at it very clearly very
in detail here okay
the
you're in the subway okay you're inside
suddenly the subway accelerates it could
be a truck it could be a train it
doesn't really matter it suddenly
accelerates and suddenly you feel that
you're falling backwards
you're hanging on but you're something
is forcing you to go backwards
and you say well
you know one file says it you're being
pushed back this
last one and another fella might say you
just stayed in place
and the vehicle accelerated left you
behind
okay but it didn't leave your feet
behind
and you say well it didn't leave my feet
behind because there's friction the feet
are in contact directly with a vehicle
with a platform you know wherever you're
standing right
and so your feet went forward
but the rest of your body didn't follow
through
well why i mean
isn't your whole body connected
and so you say well yeah it's connected
but
it's malleable
it's like water it's like gas
it's not rigid like a steel beam if i
were like a steel beam and i you know
the um
and i'm sitting on the platform it i
would go completely you know my whole
body would go forward but since i'm
malleable the upper part goes backward
but it turns out your whole body is
interconnected
you know you're a bunch of atoms they're
all interconnected
you are connected why do you move the
rest of your body except your feet right
where does the rest of your body move
backwards or stay backward when your
feet move forward
that's the question okay
okay so let's move on here
i did a little uh experiment
uh
let me get rid of this
i did a little
experiment people like experiments so
we're going to do an experiment just
it's really not an experiment what it is
is to illustrate for you the difference
between a rigid object
and a malleable object we're going to
compare a pencil
inside a container as these people call
it you know their car is a container of
air in a
whatever was in there right so a car is
a container they talk about the
container we're going to put a pencil
inside a container
now a pencil is more or less rigid its
atomic structure is rigid
so when the container moves forward
the
pencil does not
deform
you know it doesn't grow big on one end
and
smaller on another end there's no flow
of atoms okay
and so here's the experiment okay watch
closely
okay i'm going to push the pencil
i'm going to push the container
containing the pencil okay the pencil is
just the exact size of the container i
move it forward you can see there's no
uh
change in the structure of the pencil
just because i moved it eraser first the
tip uh did not grow bigger
okay
the entire pencil moved together with
the
container and so we all say well okay
that's obvious i know that okay
so i'm glad you do okay so we know what
happens with a rigid object it doesn't
deform and it doesn't all the atoms
don't pile up at one end
but something different happens when
we do it with water okay so here's water
okay same experiment okay
here's water
and what we're going to do we're going
to push that thing forward and you're
going to see how the water piles up in
the back there and there's going to be a
gradient in the water level
and here it goes i'm going to do it
several times so you can see what's
happening i'm going to push it forward
and you can see how the water
immediately piles up in the rear
okay
same experience you you have you can try
this at home always in the presence of a
relativist right
um
and you'll find out that the water goes
to the rear piles up in the rear of the
container which is what
we're saying is happening with the air
inside the van
and with any uh malleable
entities such as you
when
when the
subway moves forward your feet
you know go with the subway be
essentially because you're essentially
stuck to the ground in the sense that
there's friction there pulling on the
soles of your feet
but the rest of your body doesn't follow
through
and and so the question is um
why is that the case
why um
why
are uh rigid things
different than uh malleable things such
as water and air or you
okay so we need to establish what that
difference is okay
to find out why the pencil did not stay
back any atom whereas the ones of water
and ox and air did stay back
remain behind okay
okay so let's look at it in detail here
okay we're gonna go slowly because these
flat earthers man they're
very difficult nuts to crack okay so
here we go we're gonna show this in slow
motion more or less i'm gonna do a
couple of these okay here it is here's
the pencil
and it's inside the van okay
and we're just gonna put the pencil
against the back of the van some giant
pencil if you want to see it that way
and you can see that it doesn't deform
the entire pencil goes forward because
it's a rigid object on the other hand
you can see that the van left a tree
behind
okay
because it's stuck to the ground it
didn't take it with it partly because
it's not part of the van partly because
it's stuck to the ground in the case of
the rigid um pencil it moved forward
without any deformation essentially
right why because
it's a rigid object okay so this is our
experience it doesn't deform
okay what happens now if we try it with
uh water or air okay
and well it's gonna be a little
different
and what we're gonna be looking at is
the fact that the pencil you know has a
different molecular structure crystal
structure you could say right it's a
different molecular structure
than
water or gas that's why we call these
solids we call the others liquid and the
other one's gases okay there's a
difference somewhere in there
and that's what the differences look
like okay
okay this is what uh
these if you had the eyes of god you go
go in there and see it in in fine detail
you would see something like this
now there's a problem with this this is
from the establishment okay and what you
see is that you see a ball and stick
model here the balls we understand those
are atoms okay different kinds of atoms
color coded in this case
what are the sticks
well the sticks are known as bonds
and the question is what do you mean
bond what is a bond is it a physical
entity
i mean what is this james bonds i mean
what what are these bonds
and you never get an answer you won't
find an answer anywhere on the internet
what a bond is i mean is it a physical
object
or is it an abstract concept that the
mathematicians use to separate two atoms
okay because it looks like all those
atoms are interconnected by these bonds
okay one
atom is tied to another atom they're
bound somehow because of this
stick
and in the case of
solids that stick is a little more rigid
than in the case of liquids and gases
and so here here's the uh evidence proof
everybody wants everyone's proof here's
authority for you okay for all those who
believe in authority okay here are these
different
people who talk about it
first one says space is thought as of as
being threaded throughout with
electrical and magnetic tensions
okay so threaded throughout with
tensions whatever those are you can't uh
thread with tensions you need a physical
object you're gonna do some threading
okay
another one says a chemical bond acts
like a stiff spring
stiff
spring
talking about an object there
connecting nuclei as a result the nuclei
in a molecule vibrate rather than
maintaining fixed positions relative to
each other okay so there's this bond
whatever bond is
that
somehow connects any two atoms there
okay that's what they're saying
another one a field in physics may be
envisioned as if this space were filled
with what interconnected vibrating balls
and
springs
and yet another one wiggling one charge
causes the field lines attached to it to
wiggle and after a time the other charge
starts to wiggle it's just like a rope
connecting to rocks
the wave here consists of a wiggling
line of electric force which you can
think of as being attached to the
vibrating charge
okay so all of these
say essentially the same thing they're
saying that atoms are connected by
something physical that they call a bond
but when you look for the word bond in
chemistry or in physics
mathematical physic mathematical
chemistry you know they don't talk about
a physical entity they use the word bond
bond meaning binding bonding
it binds two atoms together right
interconnects them
and one moves the other meaning there's
something physical between the atoms
right
but it turns out that they treat these
mathematically they just talk about what
the amount of force is on that bond what
the tension is maybe but they never
identify what the bond is you certainly
won't find these bonds in the
uh standard model of quantum mechanics
so uh we have no idea what this bond is
what do you mean to bond what what is
this bond is it a stick is that what
we're saying
is it a spring as they're saying
something that you know moves back and
forth different tensions
is that what it is are we talking about
a spring
or is it just a mathematical concept an
abstraction that they use
ad hoc because they need to
tell you that
atoms react to other atoms somehow
action at a distance
mediated by whatever a bond is
okay this is the issue
okay that these people mentioned the
word bond but you never find out what a
bond is okay james bond again
okay so here we have
water
we're going to accelerate
the car and you can see how they pile up
the the molecules of water or gas could
be air it doesn't matter or we can do uh
uh air here okay so what these people
are saying is that when the
back of the car hits the first atom or
molecule right
it pushes it against the next one which
pushes it against the next one when it
pushes it against the next one this is
their notion and they say
you know nothing
compels
these
atoms these molecules to stay in place
it's just that when the car hits it when
the container the rear of the container
hits them and piles them up one against
the other that's when they all start to
move that's why they pile up in the rear
of the van that's their argument
okay
so let's uh look at what they're missing
okay this is what they're missing this
is what they have to answer
okay we're going to move
very slowly here we're going to find out
that
the
atoms or the molecules stay in place
until something touches them
and the question is
we're not concerned about the car
pushing
all the molecules forward or one
molecule against the other we're
concerned about why those molecules are
staying in place until something hits
them until something comes in contact
with them being other molecules or the
car doesn't really matter but before
something touches them why do they stay
in place
until
something touches them
that's the question okay and these
people are saying nothing causes them to
stay in place
that's the answer you receive
and again it's like saying nothing
causes this pencil to fall down
it always falls down bill yeah i know
i understand that much you know the
question is what causes it to come down
there's nothing causing it because i
can't see or touch anything
that's why
nothing causes this to happen
okay so why does it move sideways why
does it move upwards well
we don't know right all we say is it
always comes down and the big problem
here is that all these people all these
people are so used to these um
things these phenomena that it's like
second nature to them so they never
question it why does the air stay back
they say well it does
that's their answer it just stays there
until something pushes it
okay it never occurred to them that
something is holding on to that thing
until something pushes it
okay
this is the issue
okay so uh
here's uh how we explain this we're
saying
there is something holding on to the
molecule we're saying that every atom in
the universe is bound to every atom in
the universe they're all physically
connected as you just heard all these
testimonies stiff spring
uh binding the bonds okay those are the
bonds these are the ropes those are the
ones that bind one atom to any other we
can't see or touch them we can't run an
experiment to determine that they're
there so don't bother this is a question
of imagining of visualizing what could
be holding on to that molecule we're
saying that there are
uh entities there are um
impinging on that atom they're binding
it to every atom on earth as shown there
and so when the van accelerates you
don't need
uh for the van to really come in contact
to to exp with that molecule to explain
why that molecule stayed in place it
stayed in place because something held
on to it and those are the what we call
the electromagnetic ropes that
interconnect every atom in the universe
and which interconnect that molecule to
every atom on earth that's the
explanation we give
okay that's why it stayed
in place that's that's what held it in
place until the back of the car hit it
and again uh we have to put uh mr
mueller uh richard muller again we put
him on and people are not listening
they should listen to mr miller because
he's telling you like it is okay so here
it goes one more time
listen carefully
what's the force of gravity on me um
it's the pull of the earth on my body
so for example if you have the earth
with its big mass here and then and you
have you
with your little mass here
that every atom on the earth
is pulling on every atom of you
you're also pulling on it
on the other hand a lot of atoms here
you're pulling on you're pulling on all
of them amazing thing about gravity is
it goes right through things
okay
do we
do we understand what's going on here
okay
we're saying that every atom
on earth is being pulled or connected to
every other atom on earth
okay and like uh
mr mueller just said
uh every atom of you is pulling on every
atom of the earth every atom on the
earth is pulling on you because gravity
goes right through things
and i don't know if that sunk into the
head of any flat earth or flat or
uh
flat universe or electric universer
every and let me repeat that i'll repeat
it 100 times if necessary every atom in
your body is pulling on every atom on
earth every atom on earth is pulling on
every atom of your body
what part don't you understand
okay how do you pull if not with some
elongated object a thing
if you say there's nothing here
and this just falls to the ground you're
saying this is done by black magic
action at a distance is black magic you
have no explanation
if on the other hand you say look every
atom in this pencil is bound to every
atom on earth then we can see why this
falls to the ground because as it falls
all those roasts
you know open up
and as they open up the acceleration is
greater and greater and greater
that's the mechanism now we have a
mechanism for gravity
okay and so the question now again is
the same for
our little atom there our little
molecule
it's being held in place more or less i
mean it is moving around because air
does move around okay but they're all
more or less held in a region
they don't move as fast as a car in one
direction especially not sideways if
anything they're being pulled down
whereas there's a flow of air inside the
car but all of them are stuck to the
every atom on earth
every atom of the molecule or atom let's
just deal with atom every atom of the
every um
every atom of the air
is being pulled by every atom on earth
the earth also pulls on it
okay so one is pulling on the other in
other words there's a tension between
them that's more or less what keeps it
in place when the car accelerates
obviously the air does not accelerate as
fast as the car as people have mentioned
and that's why the car ends up the
container ends up hitting and piling up
all these atoms towards the back of the
car
okay so now we have a mechanism because
there is a physical object that is
holding onto the molecule until the back
of the car piles them all up against the
back of the car
that's the explanation
okay so let's apply
muller
to the
rope model here we have it okay
there we have it uh
every atom on the earth is pulling on
every atom of you you're also pulling on
it
and the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things so
there you have it ever that's the reason
the molecule stayed in place because it
was held there by all the
uh ropes that are converging upon it
from the earth from you from everything
and yes it does move it still moves a
little bit but not as fast as the car
that's the issue so they more or less
get piled up once the back of the
van starts piling them up towards the
rear of the car
okay uh you still don't believe let's
put some more evidence okay of how
things are interconnected here's another
fellow you must have heard of someday
his name is brian green and this is what
he has to say about
interconnectivity out there in the
universe okay
the problem is some of these people
don't pay attention to what he's saying
in fact brian green doesn't pay
attention to what he's saying either he
just
without any cause or reason he dismisses
interconnectivity after saying that it
is like if everything were connected and
here it is
how does gravity actually work
how does the earth pull on the moon
across hundreds of thousands of miles of
empty space
they behave as if they're connected by
some kind of invisible rope
they behave as if they're connected by
some kind of invisible rope
but everyone knew that wasn't true
so
do we have interconnections between the
moon and the earth do we have
interconnections between
you and the earth do we have
interconnections between the molecule
inside the car and the earth
and the answer is yes because if you
don't put an interconnection there
you're going to explain that ex
those phenomena with black magic you're
gonna say it just happens it happens
from action at a distance whatever that
is it's mass it's density it's uh
gravity there's a concept you can't say
that's what we're trying to answer you
can't say density caused this to happen
gravity caused this to happen mass
caused it to happen force energy you
can't use any of those words those are
concepts you got to tell me what
physical object is in contact with a
molecule otherwise you're doing black
magic you can't replace
objects with concepts and say i'm going
to do it with a concept
that's where the problem is and that's
how mathematical physics does it they do
it by
um
introducing concepts such as field force
wave whatever those are all concepts
yeah those are not physical entities
okay uh
so now you know what the question is you
got to tell me what physical object is
in contact with a molecule that stopped
it there which retained it there which
made it stay there which uh forced it to
stand still okay that's the question
okay here's another flat earther and he
says the phone said we do not actually
know that the physical earth is rotating
we do not know that the physical earth
is a globe aha
we are told it is but there is no
science test direct measurement to
confirm either of those directly
curve of the earth isn't actually
checked
there is no explanation as to how to
test it is true in the real world
if it is true in this real world there
is no direct evidence that water
ever curves
okay so we have a problem because this
person is talking about uh
you know
running a test of some kind some kind of
measurement that he wants he wants to
verify he wants to check it test it
experiment and you can't use any of
those those are all belong those all
belong to religion okay so whenever you
use the word no test measure confirmed
all those at the bottom there convince
convert persuade you're talking about
religion
okay so all this person wants his
religion he wants someone to convince
him that the earth is round
you know and and uh
i'm not sure what he wants
as a test what kind of test he says i'm
going to measure it i'm going to walk
the
you know all around the earth to find
out if i come back to my starting point
i don't know i don't know how he's going
to prove to himself you know with some
kind of experiment that the earth is
round
and
you know
the way we look at it is here we see it
this is how we prove that the earth is
round if all atoms are physically
interconnected if they're all bound to
each other then we can see why both
water and air curve around the earth
spherically spherical earth right so
it's this is a spherical shell that
covering that's enveloping the earth uh
that's air there the blue the dark blue
is water it's all roundish why because
all atoms are pulled towards the center
of the earth
every atom in your body is
pulled by every atom on earth every atom
on earth is
pulled it pulls on you and you pull on
it that's that's the situation okay so
until you get a handle on that okay let
me get these out of here until you get a
handle on that
uh you're gonna be spinning your wheels
you're gonna say it's all done with
nothing with concepts such as mass and
density and who knows what else
no you gotta put a physical object
physics first and foremost
is a discipline that deals with objects
without objects you can't do physics
imagine there were nothing in the
universe
what would be happening what experiment
would you be running other than you you
know you're the only object right what
would you be doing if there's nothing
out there
now you need to have objects to do
physics and there are invisible
intangible objects that you will not be
able to elucidate you will not be able
to zero in on them by running any kind
of experiment experiment meaning i hand
right
you can't run an experiment
to detect that which is invisible
intangible which is what mother nature
uses to do
gravity
okay
okay uh
we're going to do a little bit of
rational science but before we do
rational science we need to find out
what irrational science is what is the
irrational scientific method and yeah we
have the irrational scientific method
that was inherited from the 17th century
supposedly there was a revolution called
or known as the scientific revolution of
the 17th century what they did they say
they overturned the greeks
for all these years approximately 2 000
years they were doing greek science and
greek science was you know a lot of it
was hocus pocus they did not do
experiments to test their
hypothesis as it's known today
and so that's what changed in the 17th
century they say let's do experiments to
prove to test
you know uh what actually happens
and so the big
test was the one that convinced everyone
uh was galileo's test apparently uh that
he apparently dropped two balls one uh
heavier than the other apparently from
the entire pisa
in italy and uh they one the heavier one
did not fall faster than the lighter one
as aristotle suggested uh in fact they
both fell at the same time
well the first thing uh you should know
is that um
stevens
uh hollander he did it
way before uh um
galileo and even before him there were a
couple of italians among them galileo's
teacher who already had done that test
so they already knew what galileo put in
print the only reason we credited
galileo today is because newton
mentioned galileo that's the only reason
okay so everybody thought the thing
started with galileo and it's not even
sure in fact it's very doubtful that he
carried out
uh the two balls from the tower pisa
experiment i don't think it ever
happened and the reason for that that i
don't think that happened is
galileo started doing his weight his
mass experiments in about 1604 at the
beginning of the century
he was put in uh
under house arrest
after his trial which was i think 1638
thereabouts and there he picked up again
he went back
to doing uh weights and masses
he he wrote his book
right after while he was in in under
house arrest
and what he did at that point was he
rolled apparently he rolled balls down
inclined planes and that's how he
determined that one goes at the same
speed as another he checked the speeds
and all this kind of thing with some of
the clocks he
and antiquity
you know some of the clocks he had uh
water clocks
that he had in those days but he never
went to the tower piece of partly
because he was under house arrest so
i don't think he ever threw any balls
from tarpis unless he did it in 1600 for
which there is no record of that at all
okay so what's the issue well well we
know before we can talk about the
scientific method it'd be nice if we
define it and so let's look up the
scientific method see what it is okay
and here's one version of it and this
comes from the american heritage
dictionary
it's a scientific method the principles
and empirical processes
empirical
that sounds like technology not like
science
empirical we don't empiricize anything
in science
science we have to explain something
okay you can do all the experiments you
want that doesn't mean you understood
what you did
and so it says empirical processes of
discovery and demonstration necessary
for scientific investigation
well hold it
is science demonstration or science
investigation
it science the detective who's in his
dark basement doing experiments to try
to learn something
you know discover something maybe or is
it demonstration the prosecutor who goes
in front of the jury and explains
what he understands what he knows
explains a mechanism a cause
which one's the scientist
so demonstration and investigation
don't go well together because one
refers to the
detective and the other one to the
prosecutor
these are two different
uh disciplines you could say so we got
to choose which one is the scientific
method
and what they did they put you know they
they covered all the bases they said
it's all of it
yeah no kidding that way you you know
you have nothing to attack because if
you attack one they say no but it's
demonstration and say oh demonstration
no it's investigation and you can never
win okay yeah when you cover all the
bases it's very hard to play ball okay
okay generally involving what the
observation of phenomena so you observe
you gawk you didn't understand squat but
you're a scientist because you observed
okay so you observed birds all day long
you didn't understand squat what they're
doing but you say hey i did my eight
hours i punched my card
you know um
i understood nothing but hey i gawked
all day long i drooled
so that's science drooling
the formulation of a what hypothesis
concerning the phenomena
well what's wrong with this the the
problem is that they never figured out
what a hypothesis is
okay when you look up hypothesis on the
internet you find
all these different versions of what a
hypothesis is here it is one says that
objective state the purpose or
hypothesis upon which the project is
based the purpose
another one says a hypothesis is your
question
another one says it's a single tentative
guess
it's a hunch
another one says it's an assumption
another one says it's an explanation
with some evidence and testing behind it
uh another one says it's a theory but
it's a provisional one
and again says tentative theory and yet
another one says it's just data analysis
that's what a hypothesis is
so we have all these versions of
hypothesis and of course if we have so
many versions we don't again they're
covering all the bases we're saying a
hypothesis is all of the above it's a
prediction it's an explanation it's an
assumption it's everything
so we've got a problem because they
never define the word hypothesis in a
scientific way
okay that's the problem so to say
formulation of a hypothesis we don't
know what they're talking about maybe
they formulated a prediction
maybe they did an observation maybe
that's what they're they say go observe
okay i observed
what does that mean
you know so we don't know what a
hypothesis is okay until they
uh zero in on that key word
we don't know what the scientific method
is about
but uh then i continue experimentation
uh to demonstrate the truth or falseness
of the hypothesis
truth falseness that's an opinion what
is true to you is a lie to your neighbor
so yeah that is religion so to say that
experimentation to do an experiment to
prove
falsity or truthfulness
you're talking about religion not about
science and so if that's part of the
scientific method of the 17th century
obviously you know it's bunk it's
irrational
and finally says in a conclusion that
validates or modifies the hypothesis
validates you mean approve of it you're
the peer and you say i like your that's
an opinion also
you know so validate has nothing to do
with science validate just means
religion means that your peer approved
and gave you a medal for what you did
but there's another peer over there or
unpeer and he disagrees with you what
about him
you know so
validate means nothing you know valid is
just an opinion
especially with some of the modern
experiments
where there is no chance to validate
what you have is you know now they're
accelerating so-called particles at the
cern and some of these other places
and they also do some tests like nasa
sends
probes into outer space
can you validate that by running your
own
rocket from your backyard and validate
what they did
now you have to take the word for it
because there is no validation
and if you have all these peers who
were
cut with the same mold you know i mean
they were all educated in the same way
and the guy at cern says oh i confirmed
what they did at slack and slack
confirmed what they did at fermilab and
fermilab and who knows what the european
whatever you know
accelerators well if if all these people
validate each other because they all
believe in the same thing they were all
educated in the same way
then what kind of validation is that i
mean hopefully you get someone who's
outside that group
and he validates
and the question is again can you run
your own accelerator in your own
backyard you know to verify what these
people are doing
no obviously not so whatever they
conclude
has no validation whatsoever
okay here we have the collins dictionary
it also has a version of the scientific
method let's find out what that's all
about scientific method a method of
research
again is is that what uh
scientific method is it's research or
demonstration
well research sounds like r d looks like
technology
what's technology well there you have it
uh designing uh or developing gadgets by
trial and error that's that's what
r d is so if you're going to do research
and development you're not doing science
you're doing technology
okay
it says in which a problem is identified
okay you identify the problem
uh relevant data is gathered okay so you
collect data is that science a
hypothesis is formulated okay from these
data again we don't know what a
hypothesis is and the hypothesis is
empirically tested
and so you test it and what does that
give us well that gives us an opinion
because one guy tested and said well i
agree with this that's what happened
does that mean that he knows how it
happened what caused it to happen what
the mechanism is
no it's just description just it
happened
and we measured and this is the equation
that's it that's called science
this is the problem the problem is none
of this is science because what they're
doing essentially is you know saying
that um
you know that
what they're just going to do is
observe measure get an equation publish
and do it all again and the other guy
does the same thing
some experiments they can verify some
they can't when they do verify who
verifies it well you know another guy
who thinks the same way and the guy who
verified the opposite and said well i
didn't verify what you said
well they either dismiss him if he's
minority and they overrule him they over
uh overvote him you have people like
halton arp okay who was uh astronomer
who was overruled
he didn't agree with uh what they were
seeing out there in the sky he had a
different opinion so they got rid of
them that's it they said well you're not
part of our
group of peers and we're gonna kick you
out so that's how they salted
so we do have people who have different
uh versions
different explanations
and if they're a minority they're just
kicked out and so
is that science or is that just politics
okay so this is the problem serious
problem
okay here we have uh synthesis of what
what i call the mathematical method
which is the 17th century revolution
what they created you observe
okay so you gawk
yeah drew okay
you explain
tentatively apparently that's what a
hypothesis is
in in mathematical physics
you make a prediction you say ah i'm
going to predict what's going to happen
because i understand very well what's
going to happen
and again you know we can we can always
uh fool anyone who does a prediction
uh and shown that he never predicted
anything he can predict that there's
gonna be an eclipse tomorrow and it
turns out that an asteroid destroys the
earth or the moon and the eclipse never
happened
and
you can predict that your horse is going
to win because the other ones are very
very slow
and i bet on the slowest horse in the
group
and just before your horse is about to
reach the finish line i shoot him down
and shoot all the other horses and let
mine win he just gallops through the
finish line you didn't know what i was
going to do see
and so predictions is nonsense okay it's
only religious people who do
foretelling and palm reading you know we
don't do that in science
okay experiment we don't need
experiments in science because you can
do an experiment what does that mean
that you know that you understood
just because you did an experiment you
go to the lab your teacher tells you you
know your chemistry teacher says mix the
blue
liquid with a red liquid
okay and it goes kapow
never do that again
and did you understand why that happened
or you say well i did the experiment
so i'm a scientist
no just doing experiments doesn't do
anything you have to understand what you
did
what the cause what the mechanism was
then you then you're a scientist then
you use your brain but to say it
happened i put the
uh red liquid with a blue liquid and
suddenly it turned in green or it blew
up well all you did all you have is a
description is that what you're going to
put on your
report it happened
you know is that is that science
uh described mathematically they call it
a theory no description is not a theory
a theory is an explanation but that's
what they do they describe
mathematically and call those theories
then they invent technology what to
confirm the theory is that what uh any
technology is for say ah we have a
quantum computer that proves that
quantum is correct
and then they say well we don't know how
quantum works
entanglement we have no idea
superposition we have no idea how that
works it's just mystical to us
so they don't understand it but they
proved it well how they proved it by
making a computer and they said it's a
quantum computer they put the adjective
quantum in front of it they quote that
qualifier and now they have the quantum
computer and that means it proves
quantum
that's the way they look at it okay now
it doesn't prove because
technology does not prove
a theory an explanation
you know
quantum computers do not prove that a
particle can be at two places at once
which is what quantum
theorizes
and gps does not prove
that time is a physical object that you
can dilate that you can stretch or
shrink or whatever
okay so
gps does not prove anything and quantum
computers doesn't prove anything gadgets
do not prove anything okay the question
is does time dilate can you stretch time
the answer is absolutely no okay
and because it's a concept we don't
stretch concepts in uh in physics
okay then what you do is convince other
mathematicians okay um for that you have
to present proof evidence you know facts
and they accept those they say okay
you've proven it we're convinced
again uh that's religion we're not
talking about
something objective we're talking about
something subjective where you convince
someone to believe like you do that's
all they did here
and then uh someone else says i'm gonna
verify your measurements okay so you
measured the table and said yep you're
right it was one meter and one
centimeter long
so you verify it as measurement that's
science because you verified the other
guy's measurement
got the same equation
again nonsense
then you and obviously if
you did it right all your peers love you
then they'll
give you a prize and
you know maybe a gold medal of some kind
and then you walk the circuit the
celebrity circuit okay
that's uh in a nutshell what the
mathematical method is that is what they
say is the scientific method in a
nutshell
okay
what are the results of this so-called
scientific method
today
what kind of
results do we have today okay
using this so-called scientific method
that they inherited from
17th century's like
galileo and
newton well here it is okay
these are just some examples off the top
of my head
big bang creationism they say that the
matter came in from nowhere suddenly
matter self-created
in other words
it's creationism without god
in traditional religions you have god
creating the first bit of matter okay we
don't know where god came from what they
say that he's eternal he was never born
he never died he never had a mother he
doesn't have a belly button okay fine
uh that's easier to believe that
than um to say that the matter just came
in
from the void
when uh black the big bang also created
the void created in space created
nothing the vacuum
and so you have the creation of nothing
and the creation of something what was
there before something and nothing
that's the question
i mean nothing is as nothing as it gets
and they say well before nothing there
was nothing
before space there was space and in
within that we created something we
don't know how it self created itself we
don't care
but it it did happen and uh
so here's the movie of uh big bang okay
they always go to frame number two they
never go to frame number one
okay they say look the theory says that
if you take
all the galaxies which are flying apart
from each other today if you get them
closer and closer together like they
were in the past at some point you're
going to reach some singularity which is
frame number two there and we call that
singularity the big bang that's what it
exploded and you say well hold it how
did that singularity get there
okay
and remember that space was also created
space is inside the little
dot there the frame number two dot
and the black stuff i had to put
something around it just to
give it some contour okay but really
that uh black stuff around the little
dot should not be there because that's
not space space is inside the dot
so we have
matter and space that's the singularity
zero dimensional singularity somehow
contains matter in space
that's frame number two there's nothing
outside of it so so we cannot contrast
it there's no contour to that little
point i had to put it in there by hand
because i had to show you something but
then the question is you say what
happened in frame number one how did
that little dot appear
to begin with
and a singularity and they say well you
know the theory we don't know what
happened before frame number two we
start always at frame number two well
that's cheating see that's cheating for
several reasons first because a
singularity is not an object it's a
concept it's a concept that says if you
take something infinite and make it
infinitesimally small
you never approach zero it just
approaches
zero it never is zero it just approaches
zero and then you say well what's
outside of that little dot what is that
little dot pushing up against and they
say well there's nothing outside of it
yeah no kidding i thought nothing was
also inside of it what is that black
stuff against
you know that against which uh
this space-time this big bang is
expanding
against in other words what is what is
uh
it pushing against we need to identify
that black stuff in order to give
contour to our little dot and of course
they say well we don't know what
happened before well they don't even
know what happened in frame number two
because frame number two is already
irrational it's irrational because space
time and matter is inside that little
dot and that black stuff should not even
be there to give it contour
and if there's no contour what the hell
is that singularity
okay this is the issue
okay so uh
those are the problems with the big bang
but getting back here we have the black
hole it's there it's a zero dimensional
object now how irrational is that
what do you mean
black hole is zero dimensional no size
no dimensions no no length width or
height nothing
i mean that is the definition of nothing
and some people say well bill you get it
wrong
black hole is not zero dimensional
well so for these people we again have
to educate them they are ignorant people
who do not understand what a black hole
is so let's educate these ignorant
people okay here's the black hole
according to mr stephen honking
and he says chandrasekhar calculated
that a cold star more than about one and
a half times the mass of the sun would
not be able to support itself against
its own gravity would it collapse to
infinite density what is infinite
density no volume
that's what it is
eddington was shocked by that
implication and he refused to believe
chandrasekhar's result eddington thought
it was simply not possible that he start
could collapse to what a point
einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not shrink
to what
zero
size
zero
size a black hole is zero size a
singularity is zero size no volume no
dimensions no nothing
and it says well chandrasekhar won the
nobel prize for proving that
a black hole collapse or in other words
a star collapses to zero size if it's
big enough
and then another fellow he's from
cambridge
big shot
astrophysicist there says unsolving the
equation with a particular value rho of
central density you will get a model of
a star with mass m and radius r plot r
is a function of m and show that r falls
to zero
when m is equal to the chandrasekhar
mass if you can do all these then you
have repeated the calculation for which
chandrasekhar won the nobel prize so
anyone who says anything other than a
black hole the zero size is an ignoramus
okay he doesn't know what he's talking
about
okay and here just in case
let's rub it in
we have a circular circularity in the
argument again it's a circular argument
the circular argument is that a black
hole
in other words a star crushes all matter
out of existence by the time it
becomes a black hole there is no matter
and if there is no matter what you have
a black hole is what it's all mass and
no matter but mass is the quantity of
matter or a measure of the quantity of
matter
and
if a black hole crushes all matter out
of existence
then you have no mass
so not only do you have no mass you have
absolutely nothing because you have a
black hole is
whatever something for lack of a better
word it's really a nothing that has no
size and no mass whatsoever because it
has no matter
so what is a black hole well a black
hole again is nothing that's what a
black hole what they've defined is
nothing it has no mass no size
no matter no nothing it's just vacuum
okay so that's what the definition of
black hole is and there you see on the
left uh what is mass well they don't
even know what a ma what mass is they
define it as the quantity of matter on
the one hand and they tell you there's
seven different kinds of or different
definitions of the word mass okay
and
again if the black hole crushes all
matter out of existence then you have no
mass and that's what a black hole is a
nothing that has no size no matter no
mass
okay they also have dark matter and dark
energy
these are dark matter is an ad hoc
variable that's apparently produces some
kind of gravity
and dark energy is the opposite it's
anti-gravity it pushes everything
outwards out there in the universe
that's what is causing the expansion of
the universe according to all these
individuals but the funny part is over
there in the upper right says that a big
percentage is like over 70 percent is
dark energy uh what is it 23
is dark matter
and that's they say a measure of their
ignorance there you have 96 percent
that's a measure of their ignorance or
what they don't know what they can't see
they can't see or touch
dark matter or dark energy okay so
again for those who talk about see touch
you know the object b and c touch well
apply it here what is dark matter if you
can't see or touch it what is dark
energy if you can't see or touch it what
is a black hole if you can't see or
touch it
okay
and uh yeah then you have particles at
two places at once okay you cannot even
imagine that okay so these are
irrational explanations that the
establishment has what's a wave packet
can anyone draw it no it's unimaginable
so you can't draw you can't illustrate a
wave packet penrose there uh drew a
corkscrew with a arrow
going right through a center a
ridiculous nonsense that he put in a
book okay
so uh
roger penrose nobel prize by the way
okay and this is the nonsense they
published
big uh men with big degrees with big
names
and this is what they draw kindergarten
stuff then no one can even imagine
that's the wave packet there
an excited field in uh here here you
have an excited field okay what is a
field well field is a bunch of numbers
that's what it is okay in the religion
of mathematical physics a field is a
physical quantity okay that has a value
for each point in space time what are we
talking about we're talking about
numbers a quantity
that has different values for different
locations in space time okay that's what
they're saying that's what a field is
field is a bunch of vibrating numbers i
mean it's if it's an excited field right
a field is a set a fundamental algebraic
structure no no such thing as an
algebraic structure that's not a
structure it's called a it's known as a
concept okay mathematicians have the bad
habit of calling structure so that which
ain't
okay and then we have the atom you can't
illustrate it and there you have the
atom that they use for ionization for
electricity for quantum jump and that
atom there you know the question is why
does the electron fly away
what keeps it there and they put that
circle in there and they say well it's
an energy
uh level it's an orbital what is that
that's a concept that's a region
you have to tell me why what what is it
is it a uh a shell of some kind of solid
shell that prevents the electron from
flying away
okay where does it fall towards the
nucleus which was the reason they
initially investigated the atom they
they wanted to know why the electron
didn't fall into the nucleus they still
don't have an answer to that question
and then you have warp time
they say that's gravity so you have all
this these minutes and seconds that
uh the earth rolls around it can't it
can't fly out of the solar system
because all these
curved minutes and seconds prevented
from doing so
so these are the irrational explanations
that you see out there today these this
is what you'll find out there and to say
that this has something to do with
science
oh no it's nonsense absolute poppycock
that's what it is we gotta call it what
it is i'm not exaggerating here in fact
i'm if anything i'm being kind okay this
is worthless garbage
okay and what a lot of mathematicians do
they dismiss all these they're saying
well we don't know how this universe
works
uh invisible and tangible stuff they
can't deal with that and so they say
what we do is equations that's that's
our job that's what physics is equations
i thought that was math
it's when they
try to give a physical interpretation to
the equation
that's when they cross the line into
physics and that's where you get only
irrational explanations like the ones
you just heard
okay
so this is the issue
okay
here we have uh one fell i mentioned in
the past i'll mention him again his name
is donald simone and he says science
doesn't explain science describes
well he's at least got that part right
yes science from a mathematical point of
view they say science doesn't explain
science describes so that
when you ask for an explanation they
cannot give it to you a mechanism if he
understood that then he's got it right
they cannot give you an explanation
that's why they say mathematical physics
doesn't explain it just describes
meaning equations why because that's all
that equations can do okay so science
some people define it testable
explanations no such monster okay no
such monster
according to the official version the
official version is science describes
why because math can only describe okay
and they say math is the language of
science only because math describes in
the equated science not with
explanations but with descriptions
that's all they can do
and so
if math can only describe then science
cannot be testable explanations as some
mathematicians argue out there
okay so this is where the problems are
okay what is the rational scientific
method in comparison here in habit
we say it's rational explanations if
it's irrational we don't
it's not part of science period
and what are uh irrational explanations
the movement of concepts you cannot use
the word energy you cannot use the word
mass you cannot use the word field force
wave
ether
um
[Music]
what is it plasma
electricity you can't use any of those
concepts those are all concepts not one
is a physical object and the problem is
that a lot of people there out there
they confuse it or they they
were led to believe that those are
physical objects electric universers
flat universe uh and the flat earthers
all of them believe in the same thing
they believe that
these words represent objects so they
say a field field does this a field does
that it move the charge
now you have concept hitting against
concept here field is a concept charge
is a concept wave is a concept you
cannot do physics with by moving
concepts around that's irrational
rational explanations you have to have
physical
objects one surface of one object come
in contact with the surface of another
object we can all understand that that's
rational you can make a movie of it you
can illustrate it
but when you say energy hit uh mass
then we have a problem okay or convert
it into mass or the field vibrated
what are you going to illustrate what
are you going to illustrate for a
mathematical concept
so there is so that's the reason there
are no illustrations okay and we're
gonna get that in a minute with our
science critic
anyways uh there you have it uh step one
hypothesis hypothesis is a synonym of
the word assumption that's what a
hypothesis is
and it includes the objects you're going
to identify that are going to form the
basis of your theory that's what you're
going to move around
the definitions you better have solid
definitions you better be able to defend
each one of them
it's very critical to have the right
definitions
and uh and then uh part of that part of
the assumptions are the initial scene
okay
could be a series of uh
illustrations the first few frames in
your movie okay and you say this is what
happened according to me
not according to mother nature not
according to father universe god or the
devil according to me
so it's a statement of the facts it's
not the facts the facts is what they
know what god knows what mother nature
knows they know exactly what happened
they have that in their filing cabinet
we have no access to the filing cabinet
end of story we don't know the facts
especially of something that happened
all we can tell you is what we think
happened and that's a statement of the
facts not the facts okay it's your
personal statement of the facts but
that's what you're going to base your
theory on so you're going to put the
object the definition the statement of
the facts now you build your theory your
explanation your mechanism the causes
on that foundation okay that's what
we're talking about and what are you
gonna explain you're gonna explain the
mechanism you're gonna explain the
causes and read some kind of conclusion
that's our scientific method that's what
we propose
okay
okay so um
you can't have um
you can't use um
c and touch you can't use experiments
that's why we don't have it in there
okay experiments are irrelevant why
because there's no way you can use
experiments see and touch
to
detect those
medias which are invisible and
intangible
there are invisible intangible mediators
a mediator an object a thing is not that
which you can see or touch we do not use
the senses
okay it's that which has shape
and an object has shaped before you use
any senses
upon it
before you see before you touch that
thing that you're going to see or touch
had better already have shape before you
do anything
the moon had shape
before anyone on earth was born
so we did not convert the moon into an
object by seeing it or touching it
landing on it you know or seeing an
asteroid hit it
hopefully uh the blind man also
considers the moon an object even though
he can't see it or touch it right
so yeah the moon is an object because it
has shape not because the blind man
uh
finally was able to see one day and see
the moon the shape of the moon
okay and so yeah
the mediator of light
have we ever seen that a photon
a wave have we seen any of those
uh gravity what is the mediator of
gravity pencil right experiment can you
see or touch anything here no
there it goes always falls to the floor
never to the ceiling never to the left
no or the right okay
magnetism we have two magnets right and
there you go little magnets
already you can see how it pulls on it
that's already pulling on one magnet on
another is there anything that you can
see there in between
and yeah it's not coming from the
outside because you can feel it pulling
from the inside it's already dragging my
fingers inwards
okay so you can do this at home
always in the presence of a relativist
okay
and uh yeah a magnet attracts another
because there is a physical object in
between them that's doing that that job
you got to identify the physical object
the invisible intangible object that's
in there and there's no experiment that
you can run here's the experiment that's
the only experiment you ever need okay
now you know what magnetism is now you
don't need any other experiment ever now
you need to explain how that happened
okay if you can't explain how that
happened what caused it to happen
uh
then you're not a scientist if you say
that it happened and there's nothing
between those two magnets
then you're doing black magic if you say
it was a field
magnetic field
then you're doing irrationality again
you're using a concept you're saying
that a bunch of numbers which is what a
field is
you know a set of numbers that's what
caused
one magnet to be attracted to another
no the field only tells you the strength
how strong that pull is it doesn't
explain the cause the mechanism that's
why mr
richard uh feynman nobel prize he could
explain how a magnet works and you can
look him up
in youtube and you'll find out he wasn't
able to explain how magnet attracts
another he says it just does
same answer that all flat earthers
flat universers and electric universes
give you
okay so let's move on to the science
critic and what does this science critic
say well again it's in line with what we
had to say today and that's
visualization
is physics about visualization
should a theory of physics be
visualizable can you illustrate should
you
be able must you
be able to illustrate
a
mechanism of physics
well hopefully the answer is yes there i
mean if if physics deals with objects
and objects is that which has shape
then there should be no reason not to
illustrate that which has shaped all the
objects that are going to cause the
mechanism to happen okay that's the
rationale so let's see what the science
critic have to say give me a second here
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
a theorist has no excuse not to
illustrate the mechanism he proposes for
invisible phenomena such as gravity or
magnetism
bill do you know how difficult it can be
sometimes to create visualizations i
don't think every scientist has the time
to go ahead and create a movie that
visualizes the things that they are
thinking of of course there are quite a
few diagrams so that might be something
that you'll have to settle for bill
imagination is subjective not objective
i'm sorry bill but you're going to have
to settle for diagrams because
scientists are under no obligation to
provide movies to you they are not film
producers they are scientists
okay so follow says
you should not be able to
you don't have to
produce mandatory right uh
a film or of your mechanism
well the reason they do not
make illustrations i mean if you go to
the arc side the
the uh where most of the papers
scientific or so-called scientific
papers are
filed
you hardly will find any paper with any
drawing with any pictures with any
images
and the reason is
they're talking about abstractions
or like mr bourne said max born he said
physics has become more and more
abstract
and yeah the problem is that abstract is
the opposite of physical
physics is physical and these people are
doing
abstractions so they're not physicists
they're abstracts okay
and so yeah you should be able to
illustrate
a
uh mechanism a theory
the causes right
uh in physics a theory of physic you
should be able to illustrate because
that's what a theory of physics is it's
a mechanism you want to understand how
gravity works you had better be able to
illustrate the mechanism
and he says look they don't have time
they're not film producers no that's not
the reason the reason is they have no
idea what the invisible intangible
objects
are out there that are
performing all these magic tricks that
mother nature does every day okay
and again i'm going to put the same ones
up here here you see them ah when yes
give me a second here
these are the you know big bang what are
you gonna put for a zero dimensional
singularity be it a black hole or a big
bang okay what are you gonna put a zero
dimensional object what are you gonna
put for a dark matter you can't see it
or touch it
how about dark energy same thing
particle in two places at once what are
you gonna illustrate the rabbit at two
places at once i mean you're gonna
illustrate it but
what sense does that mean how are you
gonna tell someone look that's the same
rabbit at two places at once you know
what sense does that make
how about an excited field what are you
going to put a bunch of numbers that
vibrate
wave pack it what are you going to
illustrate
that's why they don't illustrate because
they cannot
all their concepts not one of them is an
object not one can be used in physics
the atom you can't illustrate it because
again if you illustrate what you see
there you're going to have to explain
why that electron doesn't fly away
and what time you know what the hell is
that you know the work minutes warp
seconds
is that what makes gps work
so again it's the the the reason they
have not been able
to illustrate and the reason they don't
illustrate is because that would be the
physical interpretation of whatever
equation they've got out there
and they say no no
mathematical physics which they call
physics is just equations
how about the the physical
interpretation we want to know how
gravity works how magnetism works you
say oh that's philosophy
we don't do that
that's not physics
that's not physics according to the 17th
century
so-called scientific revolution version
of the scientific method not according
to science genuine science which is
explain to me why this pencil
you know falls to the earth
explain to me what causes this magnet to
be attracted to the other we need an
explanation that's what they don't have
okay it's all irrational explanations
because they are putting concepts
in lieu of objects to try to explain and
others give you a physical
interpretation when it's an abstraction
explanation abstract explanation not in
physical explanation it's got nothing to
do with physics
okay uh let's get on with some of the
questions and comments people made
here's uh since last time uh here it
goes fellow says how can an object have
boundaries and at the same time be
connected by rope with everything else
in the universe well here's the
construction of our atom okay that's
what it looks like
and how does how do we construct it well
here it is you have the electric thread
the magnetic thread
one forms the proton which goes right
through the center and
every atom in the universe every rope in
the universe uh donates a uh
thread through the for the proton and
then you have the magnetic thread goes
around and encapsulate the proton what
you have is a little star there that's
what our atom looks like and therefore
it's the same rope which converges upon
our the
edge of our
atom
and then
converts
into the
magnetic uh electron shell
magnetic and electric by the way are
just arbitrary names just to keep in
with convention
and yeah once you have the same rope
converting into the atom which on the
other side converts back into a rope
well what you have is
again you have everything connected and
nothing is really attached
so it's the atomic construction which
you have to understand so it doesn't
have a boundary because one thing
converts into the other there's a single
thread in the entire universe and all
atoms and the ropes that interconnect
them is
made of that thread
so there's only a single thread in the
entire universe closed loop thread
that's our
uh ultimate hypothesis
okay another follower says
on the other side give me a second here
okay exists having objective reality you
look up reality
exist so you use the synonym to define
exist
no no go
object a collection of matter you look
up matter bunch of objects
synonym so
he's using synonyms to define the words
we can't use any of these irrational
definitions synonyms are and antonyms
are not definitions they are circular
definitions meaning no definition at all
okay i think the same fellow here says
einstein's general theory of relativity
established time as a physical thing
yeah totally irrational i mean time is
not a physical thing
absolutely now for that you have to
define thing physical and then we'll
know what you're talking about
and of course if he thinks that it's
just a bunch of matter and matters just
a bunch of things and we don't know
anything all we did was run around in
circles
it is part of space time time as a
dimension well if time is a dimension
we've got a little bit of problem
because um
you know i mean does it run
perpendicular to length width and height
so the question is is time a dimension
or is time
a number line
okay so this is the issue
time is a number line so are the
all the number lines of mathematics and
there are no dimensions
coordinates or vectors in
mathematical physics
time is one of the some fundamental
physical qualities okay if it's a
quality or quantity obviously it's not a
physical object
and time is length of change if it's
length of change then we're talking
about a concept again or the interval
over which change occurs if it's an
interval it's a concept there's no
physical object called interval okay so
it's not a physical thing
time dilation isn't just theoretical
uh so what is it uh
it says time dilates travel time day
travel dilates time what do you mean
travel dilates time
i mean you move and you stretch time huh
that's a
mighty
uh
solid object you got there or malleable
object and you see continue says five
years on a ship traveling at 99 percent
the speed of light corresponds to
roughly 36 years on earth
jesus christ i wish uh i could have
whatever he uh had to drink or eat
anyways there you see it on the right uh
you have a traveling twin guy in the
rocket and you have the
twin that stayed on earth and he just
goes around the sun
and the question is did 36 years
uh go by on earth uh
or did uh more or less five years ago he
says five years on a ship traveling
uh 99 speed of light or roughly 36 years
on earth okay so he says the
traveling twin the guy who's inside the
rock and he experienced five years and
the guy on earth experienced 36 years
this is very simple either the earth
went around the sun 36 times or it went
around the
sun five times okay that's what a year
is so either we have five years or we
have 36 years it can't be both one of
the two is wrong
okay so if uh the earth actually went
around the sun 36 times that's exactly
how many years went by
and the guy on the uh on the on the
rocket you know he he's simply wrong
okay dead wrong and he says no but i
measured it with this atomic clock very
accurate atomic clock well it can't be a
very accurate atomic clock because we
know
right we have verified we have confirmed
we understand
that clocks taken farther and farther
away from the earth uh do not take at
the same rate
so if this guy traveled around the
universe and came back and he says only
five years went by how do you know that
well i measured the years with an atomic
clock
well that first of all that's not how we
measure the years that's the first issue
and the second issue is that his clock
dilated right and so
if he's going to measure different times
at different
distances and speeds then his clock is
worthless especially didn't tell us
something about
something as objective as how many years
uh went by in other words how many times
the earth went around the sun
okay so that's one issue and then you
have the uh name brains of nasa and they
did a gravity probe b
in the 70s to prove that time is a
physical object they say it's a solid
object like a piece of steel no i'm not
exaggerating that's exactly what they're
saying they're saying that they sent
this
these gyroscopes inside this gravity
probe b and that they found that time
dilates that time stretches
okay that's what they proved they
claimed that they confirmed einstein's
theory well what they proved in other
words is that time is a physical object
that's what they claim to have proven
and so
until you understand that you have you
you remain in ignoramus okay
what they claim with the gravity probe
be is that time is a solid object just
like
uh a rubber band you know because it
dilates right so so so you have here you
know it's like that that's what they're
saying time is like this exactly like
this
that's what they proved by running an
experiment which again no one can
confirm because that's a one-time
experiment they said we verified it who
verified it the people who ran the
project
okay so uh yeah
here's time dilation for you okay
there it is that's time dilation
okay the mathematicians invariably treat
time as a physical object as this fellow
said and that's what people believe they
think it's a physical object so they
confuse the clock with the time i guess
okay another fellow says he says our
black hole is just a void where light
cannot propagate through
or as there is no ether
and now it's again it's very simple here
it is again
first of all the black hole is a
circular argument because black hole
crushes all matter out of existence
mass is a measure of a quantity of
matter but since we crushed all matter
out of existence there should be no mass
which is what a black hole is uh
made out of mass but there is no mass
because all matter was crushed out of
existence aside from the fact that a
black hole is zero dimensional because
uh they claim that the
uh
event horizon essentially
i'm sorry the star collapsed the zero
size that's what chandrasekhar approved
that's what he won the nobel prize for
so to say that
that uh black hole is something is
what's ridiculous it's defined as
nothing it's defined as absolute vacuum
uh it's designed defined as zero
dimensional no mass no matter that's
known as nothing okay
and uh
again
here we have these two gentlemen and
they proved
or they uh
gave us evidence that uh chandrasekhar
proved
that a black hole is zero dimensional if
it's zero dimensional we're talking
about absolutely nothing
and if um
the black hole uh crushed all matter out
of existence
it not only has no matter but no mass
and it has no mass and it's zero
dimensional we're talking about
nothing that's the definition of nothing
that's what a black hole is nothing
okay another father says
the ionosphere is a concept that has no
repeatable evidence
evidence is religion evidence is used to
persuade the jury we don't persuade in
science it is uh in sunday school where
they persuade okay
the electric field of earth can be
measured
absolutely not you cannot you can
measure objects you cannot measure
concepts
field is already a measurement a set of
measurements you don't measure a set of
measurements
okay
and you can measure a table a shirt a
house but you can't measure concepts
can't measure fields field is a concept
uh equipotential field lines that
dictates we sit between two gaussian
surfaces
so you look at a you look up gaussian
surface let's see what what he's talking
about okay it says a closed surface we
chain the surface by the way in three
dimensional space through which the flux
of a vector field is calculated
a so-called gaussian surface is a
concept not a structure it's not an
entity not a thing
the boundary of a three-dimensional
region boundary is not a physical entity
okay boundary is a concept and so uh
yeah you can't sit between two concepts
okay try that try try sitting between
love and hate for example see see if you
know you sit between them
okay
those are repeatable laws of physics no
in physics we have no laws the it's the
religion of mathematics which calls
their equations laws
they have nothing to do with physics or
science for that matter in science we
have no laws we only have
explanations
and a final issue here fellow says
says objects bill says you point to
while also saying it has nothing to do
with your senses
so tell me about air without using your
senses explain to me air
well we don't explain air
we say we just designate as an object
it's a under the category of object
because air has shape
okay
and so i don't know what he wants to
explain it's like saying explain to me a
chair explain to me a house
you don't explain objects okay you
explain theories not objects so what he
means explain air i don't know
so objects are that which have shape and
shape isn't what you see touch from
bill's book but examples of shape are
what you see touch
yeah
see touch are subsets of objects
but it doesn't work the other way around
not everything not every object can be
seen or touched but if you can see or
touch it then it is an object okay so c
touch or subset of objects
okay is that understood
isn't that contradictory no absolutely
not object is that which i shape is
problematic because anything including
shadows can have shape no shadow is not
a stand alone you have to be stand alone
we're not going to put that in the
definition because it's unnecessary
you're talking about when you talk about
shape in this context you're talking
about the notion of ordinary speech of
shape and no we do not have to define
the word shape because
we need a definition of the word object
and the problem right now is that
mathematical physics and everybody and
their mother out there say that an
object is that which you can see or
touch
and we're comparing shape
against c touch that's the context
that's the issue don't take it outside
of that
we don't need to define shape in any
scientific way all we have to say is is
the definition of the word object see
touch or is it shape
that's the question
all objects have shape in fact uh here
we have it here's the definition
okay
object that which i shake
definition doesn't involve the senses
okay you don't need to see shape the the
moon already had shape before you saw it
and if it has shape you have no excuse
not to point to it which has shape but
to that which has shape
air had shaped before anyone pointed at
it or figured out what it is it already
had shape okay atmospheric air has a
shape of a spherical
shell it encapsulates our planet okay
air in a balloon takes the shape of a
balloon of the balloon right and then
air in space takes the shape of a blob
and we need no container for that just
like we need no container for our
atmosphere
that's for the flat earthers who believe
we need containers to contain air to
contain molecules absolutely not and
here's
uh proof evidence okay for those who
like experiments here's the experiment
okay
we have an astronaut and he comes out of
a capsule with a balloon okay it's a
special type of balloon that can hold
air in space okay so the first thing he
does he pops the balloon
and all the air comes out
turns out the air is color-coded so we
can see it just so that the flat
earthers can see what's happening
and so what came out is that blob which
is now dispersing
in space in empty space out there okay
it's expanding it's a blob
and so the we have a couple issues that
people always raise first of all people
say well what is the shape of that blob
wrong question wrong question you you
mental [ __ ] okay
the issue is does
it have shape it's a yes or no type of
question it's not what is the shape of
it's does it have shape that's the
question you have to answer and the
question is does that blob have shape
right there in that picture and that
single frame
doesn't have shape if you say no you
have to go see enough dolmologist you
got to see an eye doctor
okay yes that does have shape that air
there that blob all those atoms they
have better half shape because every
atom in the universe has shape so if
that's a real blob okay it's made out of
atoms though the bunch of them had
better have shape
okay now does that shape change in the
next frame of the film yes it does
irrelevant
okay it's an irrelevant issue
of course a cloud does not maintain its
shape air does not maintain its perfect
shape we don't care and we don't care if
you know where it ends or what exactly
is the shape none of that matters the
issue is does it have shape in that
single frame of the movie shape is a is
a static concept you should be able to
see or imagine or conceptualize shape in
a single frame of the movie we do not go
to the second frame of the movie and say
oh but the shape changed
of course it did you mental [ __ ]
okay so that's the issue you need to
understand what you don't understand and
what you don't understand is that a blob
of air has shape you don't need uh the
flat earth to say oh you need a
container no you don't you mental [ __ ]
you do not need a container for a blob
of air that the uh astronaut just popped
after he popped a balloon it's going to
be a blob that has shaped in a single
frame it has shaped all by itself it
doesn't depend on
shadows
okay because the shadow requires three
objects at least to make it
we do not have uh dependent or
interrelated objects there's no such
monster
object stands alone and there if we're
going to call that blob air that air has
shape and the word air
in this context has shape and is an
object is a thing
part because it's made from atoms
but it's not again we don't use uh
the number of atoms a table is made to
say oh a table has a trillion atoms we
don't care how many atoms it has table
is what you point it to and no before
you point it already has shape so don't
tell me that oh
you had to use the senses no you don't
the moon had shaped before you had sense
and you still don't
okay so let's get rid of these
then uh yeah the air in space takes the
shape of a blob a single frame you can
point to it you don't need to point to
it but that's the way we present them in
physics we point to table and say table
and then the et knows what the word
table refers to
and all the objects
in
in the dictionary every word that
falls under the category of object has
shape
and all those words that do not have
shape
that do not represent that which has
shape are known as concepts so there's
only two types of words in the
dictionary one is known as object the
other one is known as concept a concept
is not uh that which doesn't have shape
but a concept is quickly you know as a
rule of thumb that's the best way to
identify a concept if it doesn't have
shape energy doesn't have shape mass
doesn't have shape
field doesn't have shape wave doesn't
have shape
none of those words has shape
okay
and until you understand that uh plasma
doesn't have shape okay so all those
words if you still have trouble thinking
that you know they have shaped and
you've got uh some learning to do
okay
can you think of an object that doesn't
have shape
okay
that's the question
and uh so take that as a homework okay
if you can think of any object that
doesn't have shave we'll be glad to hear
from you
with that i'll see you next sunday
bye bye let's